there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey everybody it's Tuesday
again and it's time for yet another
episode of the 13 o'clock podcast
episode 119 yeah this is gonna be an
interesting one this one is about the
Djinn this was actually Tom's idea I
don't think did anybody um request this
or did you yeah we actually do had we
had one I wanted to do this show before
I had mentioned it to you earlier but we
had one subscriber from Indonesia which
is a Muslim country or parsley Muslim
and he wanted to hear about jinn and the
jinn stories and you know the jinn is an
interesting concept
you know dr. Robert price talked about
jinn on occasion and jinn is basically
Islamic paranormal stuff we'll get into
it it's pretty neat yeah I actually
didn't know a hell of a lot about this
until I started doing research for it
for the show and it actually really is
very interesting yeah concept and one
that doesn't have an exact analog yatin
Christianity not quite an angel not
quite a demon not really a ghost it's
like a paranormal extra-dimensional
being known as the Djinn now in the
United States you know on our lore you
know I Dream of Jeannie
you know we Norma's kind of like a genie
and I first came face to face with jinn
stories when I was working in Boston a
guy worked in my office with me was from
Iraq and and you know this was after the
first Gulf War and you know we talk a
lot and I told him about math Mountain
poltergeist and he went oh that's a
ginned yeah and you know through his
cultural reference poltergeist is also
ginned and the more I found out about
Djinn through Jim stories the more I
could see they yeah you could describe
poltergeist as a Djinn
in a way it's actually a pretty good
it's kind of like a collective term for
a lot of things that fall under
different umbrellas like in Western
culture but to them it's like all the
same thing just manifesting itself in
different ways which is actually a
pretty good way of looking at it I
thought that's what I said it like as
long you know I've had a few days to
research this and I'm kind of hoping
that I don't mess anything up too bad
but I kind of got into it went down the
rabbit hole and I thought it was like
pretty entry yeah so hopefully I get it
sorted yeah it's like correct and for
any new listeners Jenny's not religious
she considered himself to be atheist I
consider myself to be a myth assist if
you don't know what a myth assist is is
I don't really believe in religions in a
literal sense but I I like religions I I
I see them as kind of like a mythology
to teach you certain values and certain
concepts that came from ancestors you
know that's it's a big cultural ancestry
thing locked in within all religions and
they could be useful if applied
correctly if you look you know if you
look at them the right way I'm not I'm
not too much into the fundamentalism you
know well I'm always kind of like I've
found comparative mythology and
comparative religion very interesting
and I took several classes on it in
college because it's something I've
always kind of been interested in not
because I believe any of it it's true
but I'm fascinated by how different
cultures interpret different you know
natural phenomena and things like that
and and I'm interested in what what
their belief systems tell you about you
know what they find important and their
culture and things like that so I so I
like that aspect of it a lot and like I
said gin was something I didn't know a
lot about so I'm kind of glad that you
um recommended that we do it cuz I don't
know if I would have you know
necessarily come to that on my own
cousin yeah we need to discuss gin the
concept of gin yeah but it was something
I found really interesting the more I
read about it yeah is there anything we
need to do do a couple of brief shout
outs as I said I have finished
re-recording the audio version of
faceless Bell evolved to volume two and
again
I'm sorry it's taking me so long but
it's like I'm having technical
difficulty after technical difficulty
and it's really really frustrating yeah
we captured at this time the audio
quality is very good yeah I finally got
a really good quality so I'm actually
about halfway through the editing
process so hopefully by the end of this
week I'm going to at least start
uploading it and then it'll probably be
another week or two before it's for sale
because it has to go through there you
know yeah and we'll probably give out
some free samples to people that gave us
reviews in the past yeah yeah so you
know if you've been waiting for that it
shouldn't be too much longer hopefully
we gave out a lot of free audiobooks in
the past and never got reviews from it
was the fault of the person didn't have
certain kind of Google accounts or if
they if you don't have an Amazon account
yeah like it gives you problems right
leave one so yeah that's fine right it's
just that in the future we're only gonna
give them out to people who actually
gave reviews in the past or people that
actually have Amazon accounts ya know
that they have Amazon account yeah and
like I said if you also if you want to
review can review it on audible that's
cool too yeah I mean generally the
audible reviews kind of do come over to
Amazon eventually as far as my
experience goes yeah and subscribe of
course patrons on our patreon account
get priority for all free samples yeah
speaking of patreon like I said you know
if you want to give us some money over
on patreon you can do that and I'll say
at the end what the what the URL is but
I would like to give a special shout out
to I'm a shrew one of our patrons yeah
who this week doubled their support so
thank you yeah he's like $10 a month
yeah getting more subscribers on YouTube
getting a little bit 500 before you know
it yeah like getting more getting more
comments on things like people coming
across our show and it's like yeah it's
pretty awesome we're almost coming up on
two year anniversary huh yeah I guess
well I guess this summer well [ __ ] now I
can't even remember no I think this
summer will actually be three years been
that long yeah yeah time flies I don't
know I can't man and we still got stuff
on the list we haven't done you guys I
have like the longest [ __ ]
yeah I have a separate list of like all
the pod cuz every time somebody requests
something I put it on the little list
every time somebody requests a movie I
put it on the little list and I have
this humongous so it's like if I if we
haven't got around to your topic or we
haven't got around to your movie it is
on the list we will get around to it I
do move things around depending on what
current events and what yeah it's
current events or whatever I feel like
doing like it right because sometimes
like the little thing will come up that
I've scheduled them like I don't feel I
don't have enough time to like research
that sometimes it's serial killer will
get caught which moves something up -
right exactly so yeah if there's
something going on in the news like with
particularly with true crime cases then
yeah I'm gonna move that to the front of
the line so like I said it's it's not
that we forget about you or anything
like that because I I have gotten like a
really really a lot of good yeah topics
and a lot of good movie suggestions and
stuff like that we will get to them yeah
eventually to put this in into a
perspective people for us to cover
everything that's on the list the show
will end up being the size of Art Bell
show it'll be that it'll be like that
yeah we got years and years worth of
show really I think I think we could
stretch those requests to actually be
like another five years or the work yeah
what I'm taking it doing now and there's
the bindings yeah he's like so I could
do sure you get through yeah and there's
stuff I could add to that list I swear
to god we could have our show could be
in terms of hours of in length is long
or amount of episodes be as long as
coast to coast like with art bell yeah
he was on for what ten years twenty
years yeah ages yeah we could we can
literally do this forever
yeah we're never gonna run those yeah
we're never gonna run out you know what
I mean so yeah like I said I have been
trying and one thing I want to do you
know pretty soon remember how we did
that show on creepy disappearances I
think it we did four or five different
cases I want to do another one like that
because I've gotten a really lot of good
suggestions for like weird disappearance
cases and I'm really into that kind of
stuff
I might actually after I finished my
faceless villain unsolved murder trilogy
I have been
during doing a creepy disappearances
trilogy but we'll see how that's
probably like a couple years down the
line I don't know what you see how it
goes I don't know how the audience feels
but I always wanted to do kind of stuff
like you know more towards the
conspiracy theory stuff every now and
then you know about like the central
reserve bank you know what I mean and
how governments were formed you know the
stuff on the dollar bill I don't know if
people are interested in that kind of
stuff yeah I have like stuff like
Illuminati the Knights Templar that kind
of stuff that kind of secret societies
somebody somebody wanted us to do like
all the conspiracies about the Denver
Airport which is actually yeah yeah yeah
I know and I've been to that to that
Airport so it's like it's it's really
kind of interesting so yeah yeah are
there are there secret tunnels
underneath it for doomsday and all yeah
yeah I got into that like I said with my
sister you she doesn't live there
anymore but she used to a couple years
ago yeah we get some positive feedback
on that kind of stuff maybe we can move
into that direction every now and then
yeah if we did that there's another five
years worth of episodes yeah I'm sure I
said it's like I'm I like the paranormal
stuff I'm mostly a true-crime person
that's like what my area of expertise is
pretty much so that's kind of you know
that that's easier for me to do cuz a
lot of the cases I've already written
about so I don't have to like go Reese
is like researching it and everything
like that so I you know I think we
mentioned this before and you know in
our underground series where we're
talking about things were underground
yeah being ex-military and coming out of
Fort Campbell and some of the other
stuff that we know we're up in Korea I
always wondered whether or not these
military bases the big ones here in the
United States whether or not they were
connected with underground railroads and
underground roads because it makes sense
that stuff came from the yeah in the
Cold War it would make sense that you
would assume that these bases would have
to be mutually supportive in an event of
a nuclear war and you wouldn't be able
to use surface roads see to me that
doesn't even seem that strange it's just
to me that seems like well here's this
base over here and then there's another
one like say 80 miles away and we need a
way to get back and forth without people
seeing us I've never had any I never had
any personal observations or any
personal evidence of this but at Fort
Campbell I was under the
rushon that there that that there must
have been some way to access that from
underneath the ground because some of
this equipment you know Hellfire
missiles are just how did they get there
where they flown in did they come in on
a train you know I don't know yeah and
we were stationed there we didn't know
everything about the place how it worked
but anyway that is funny because that
going underground show that was one of
the most fun ones that we did I think it
I think it's come like I think that was
one of our least yeah nobody liked it
way like it's funny because like topics
that I really had fun doing like I like
the Houdini and seance one that was one
of my favorite ones to do cuz I love
that kind of [ __ ] yeah but I feel like
that pad it's it might have more views
now cuz that was like one of our oldest
ones I just had this weird gut feeling
that the United States is totally
undermined with underground roads and
underground railroads and that they've
interconnected minds I saw a program
that said that there were salt mines and
mine shafts all underneath the United
States and that if you could map all
those mines and all the stuff that they
admit that's down there you turned it
into a map like a road map it would look
about like the map on the surface you
know what I mean yeah that it's that
undermined and I saw that program
something on The Learning Channel
decades ago and I can't find it again so
we've been looking for it there maybe
the audience no they went to one of them
and it was a I think it was some kind of
a mine of bauxite mine and they had an
underground town with three-story
buildings and playgrounds and cars and
street lights and everything and it had
been abandoned since I think the 60s
early sixties late 50s and they went
underneath there showed it and it was
like being outside at night and it was
creepy as hell they were going into
those apartments and then the calendars
were up and the beds were made and all
the dishes were put away and it was
under a thick layer like thin layer dust
and nobody had been down there forever
and it was just a bauxite mine with a
town in it an abandoned town and they
never through and the cars they had cars
in it going back to the early 50s and
when the car would break down they just
Park it in a parking lot and sat out
there for deck
and decades and decades neighbors you
know sixties cars and I think there
might have enforced uh from the forties
in it to and because why take it up to
the surface they just push the side
trucks and stuff but they had old
parking lots of cars that people drove
around in that town underneath and
sitting there in the parking lots with
all the tires rotted off and nothing
wrong with those cars you could fire
Martin if you could bring him back to
life
it was just abandoned down there because
like I said there's you know they're out
of the elements they're out of the
elements there and there were company
cars they just left them yeah but if I
got their nose that program I'd like to
see it again I'd like to show it to her
yeah I wanted to see if we couldn't find
it because he couldn't remember the name
of it earlier remember then I think uh
pretty sure it was on either Discovery
Channel History Channel yeah when they
had cool [ __ ] it would have been about
15 20 years ago I think it was amazing
the stuff that they had down there and
like I said that kind of [ __ ] creeps me
out like if it's just abandoned yeah
like oh they're still dishes left and I
wanna there's a calendar I want to say
that was somewhere either in Florida
Louisiana
been a long time though yeah I know my
memory is kind of cloudy but I remember
what it looked like well if we can find
it we'll do it creepy yeah yeah
cuz like I said I liked that going
underground what I think it's a whole
underground city just nobody in it yeah
but I think the only other shadowed I
got to do our last movie retrospective
was Stuart Gordon's from beyond starring
our buddy
Jeffrey Combs and also the very hot
Barbara Crampton in SNM Gary oh yeah
with her ass kind of flat but it was
okay it was of the times you know they
had that yeah that 80's look yeah I
guess it was cocaine inspired booty okay
[Laughter]
no but yes look like a normal lady like
a normal person I remember what it was
like back then it was all about implants
that that decade was about implants it
wasn't about booty yeah no I had not
appeared yet yeah we are
laughing about what were we watching the
other day that was [ __ ] it was some
horror movie that was set in the 80s I
can't look like a slasher movie like a
forgotten one and like we were laughing
about how that awful awful like hi-cut
underwear and bathing yeah everybody god
I remember those I hate that no we were
watching a review that's right or
watching a review and it was what was
the name of that movie it was someone
that was in those barbarian yeah yeah
and they were running around and weird
sorceress outfits and [ __ ] and it's like
you know the other wear that they wore
look like a big V up in your crack and
everything and it made a woman's ass
look flat and really tall I think I
don't know I think I'll give him the
front they were trying to make a legs
their legs look longer I think that's
what yeah I think that might have been
that might have been the thing with the
high-waisted jeans too maybe they
thought it makes your legs look longer
but it did not how it works though it
really it just makes everyone look
pregnant mad mommies we need to get we
need to get to these gen stories yeah
talking about ass we way mean we you
know he also thing that he always says
we but then he's the one that went off
on a tangent
I'm just like sitting every I don't know
is the nature of this show yeah but
that's you know you guys seem to like
that so that's fine yeah alright but
let's get to talking about gin yeah now
like I said gin is kind of like as a
concept now associated with the Islamic
religion but it actually predates that
comes from various other belief systems
in that part of the world and then was
later like incorporated into Islamic
mythology it does they do turn up in the
Koran and things like that now the
interesting thing about jinn though is
that the word jinn actually kind of
means two different things um it they
think that the root of the word comes
from
the word meaning like hidden or
concealed like a being that's concealed
from the senses invisible right yeah
like invisible like like humans can't
perceive them can't see them but then
another thing too is that the word jinn
pretty much refers to anything like that
but it also refers to like a particular
thing so it's weird because angels and
demons and jinn are like three different
things but angels angels and demons are
Jin but jinn are not necessarily angels
a Danish you know what I'm saying
there's there like a distinctive thing
but they can be used as like a more
general term for like any supernatural
entity or they can be used to refer to
like a specific type of entity yeah so
there's a like a bunch of different
types of them which I'll kind of get
into later but they're um they don't
really know like where the word came
from like I said they think it probably
came from the word meaning hidden or
whatever but there was something that
was earlier on like there's an Aramaic
word Jenaya which actually means
tutelary deity which is like a protector
spirit or like a guardian spirit so they
think that maybe that that could be
where the word came from and that at
some point these were something like
some sort of pagan deities like nature
deities or elemental spirits or
something like that that were later like
incorporated into the pantheon but like
I said they're not necessarily they're
not supernatural beings in the strictest
sense of the word because unlike angels
and demons they're not immortal they
still have to eat they sell to sleep and
sheep yeah they have houses they have
families they can procreate they can
convert to Islam they can Christian they
can be different religions be satanic
they can be anything yeah and they're
not necessarily evil they can be good or
evil but so in that way they're like
humans but like a transdimensional human
right they're just outside of our senses
in a parallel you
verse and according to the legends and
also things that were like written in
the Quran sometimes they can see you and
interact with you sometimes you can see
them and you can interact with them so
kind of what they're talking about is a
being from its own world that's just
slightly beyond this dimension yeah you
don't know you're not supposed to be in
contact with them but sometimes it
happens now
I'm under the impression that these that
this concept of Gian is far older than
Christianity and I think it's older than
Islam yeah probably older than Judaism
this is probably something I think it
sounds to me based on what I've learned
from dr. price this sounds Zoroastrian
to me probably something from Persia
that's that's where I think this comes
from and it may in some way be related
to Sumer the Sumerians had things like
angels they may have had things like
jinn
yeah but I think this is a Zoroastrian
concept do you know did you find
anything Barry is actually like I said
when I was reading about the etymology
of the word and where the word came from
where the belief might have come from
like I said there was an Aramaic word
that kind of referred to a similar kind
of thing there's also a Persian word
okay that is je I guess that's how you
project that is like a like an evil
female spirit and that is from around
the area of Iran but it was Zuo ash from
but a little bit before that
yeah pries or Oh a stream yes okay so
there's some speculation that that also
might have been where the concept came
it's folklore yeah and Islam inherited
it yeah
now if you look at the New Testament
some of the New Testament Scriptures and
you match it up with the Old Testament
Scriptures there's some disagreement
about what an angel and what a demon is
in Genesis it's inferred that a demon is
one of the sons of gods
gotten chained into the earth for
procreating with human women so it says
that so the Old Testament concept is
that a demon is a angel being punished
but if you look at the New Testament
where you have Jesus casting demons out
of a man and they go into a sin to a pig
and run out you know that man was in the
cemetery possessed by these demons so
kind of like the Christian version of a
demon is like the spirits of the evil
dead there could might be a little bit
of crossover between the concept of jinn
and spirits of the dead there's a
possibility of that so in Christianity
the concept of a jinn literally a Djinn
in it doesn't really exist I think
probably the closest thing that
Christianity has to that is what's
mentioned in the New Testament of
spirits of the Evil Dead maybe sort of
maybe but it doesn't really correlate
does it because there's no real analogue
yeah it's a concept we don't have like
in Christianity in Jude in early Judaism
early Judy Judaism they do have a
concept very similar to that but
Christianity not so much because the
whole thing about the jinn like I said
they were supposedly around before Adam
just like the angels were so they were
quite like angels were created out of
light like God created them out of light
he created the jinn out of what is
called smokeless fire smokeless fire
energy energy and then man was created
on clay or mud yeah and you see really
even in the Apocrypha there's nothing in
the Apocrypha that equates to to that
yeah yeah it is an Islamic thing they
must have inherited it from pre
Zoroastrian folklore that's yes that's
the only place this could if that's
pretty much what they're thinking
because they're not entirely sure where
the exact concept came from but there's
kind of a couple of schools at the
on this it's like some scholars are like
well maybe the gin originally referred
to spirits that hung out and like
deserts and cemeteries and like you know
that eaves and that kind of [ __ ] that's
where I was getting at with the Jesus
story it's a that's the closest
Christianity has yeah to the gin is but
the story about Jesus confronting a
possessed guy out in a damn Cemetery
possessed by the spirits of the evil
dead Jesus cast those spirits out to go
to swine they jump into the ocean that's
the closest thing we have to a jinn yeah
it it may be that if you were to tell
that story to some kind of Islamic
scholar later they'd go oh yeah that's a
jinn yeah they might make that leap and
a lot of the jinn had sort of
animalistic you know kind of like it
would sometimes have a cat head or it
would have wings or it had animalistic
tendencies you know so there's kind of
that thing and then there's some
scholars that think much like the
Christians took like pagan nature
deities and turned them into demons that
makes you think that a similar thing
might have happened in this situation to
where like other you know other
supernatural beings from other you know
belief systems in the area kind of
incorporate into gee that makes sense
because as ancient Egypt changed from
the original Egyptian religion to
Christianity and then later on into
Islam the new Islamic traditions would
have come in contact with all those
Egyptian Stella's right and they would
see Bastet and Horus and you know so
they're cat headed goddesses and and you
know falcon-headed gods and they would
just go yeah they're they're not demons
they're not evil yeah they're just jinn
that's how they would you find like the
most interesting about the concept of
jinn is that they don't necessarily like
I said they're very like people some of
them are evil some of them can be good
some of them can be helpful some can be
neutral it's like they're not
necessarily so even when you know Islam
incorporated you know
from other belief systems they don't
necessarily demonize them no just oh
well that's another thing from another
part of the world it's not necessarily
bad they can be bad but that's they're
not necessarily right and no hardcore
Islamic person would say but you can't
worship jinn that's wrong you can only
much evidence that anyone ever
worshipped them I know that but there's
no culture well what would happen is is
that a Muslim would consider the
worshipers of the ancient Egyptian gods
as worshipping jinn right not demons
yeah yeah they're baby jinn like crazy
because they wouldn't probably condemn
their own ancestors outright there's a
saying they were just incorrect yeah and
there was a you know pride kind of prior
to you know Islam expanding it was kind
of a thing where jinn were considered
that you know a lot of poets like use
them as inspiration like I really like a
poet had their personal jinn that would
like give them inspiration in their
poetry and there was also you know
magicians and stuff that supposedly
could control them you know and get them
to do their bidding much like you know
Aladdin and stuff like the one lamp that
we know about yeah it all kind of makes
sense in the traditions you know I mean
that you have Muslims looking at you
know ancient Egyptian stuff and they're
going yeah they're getting jinn to serve
them that matches with what we're saying
right now so that works out but there if
you actually read book of the Dead and
you know the ancient Egyptian cultures
and what the religious beliefs were they
were very religious people they were
very noble and they were very moral in
fact a lot of the moralistic tendencies
of the ancient Egyptians actually kind
of look like Christianity and Islam it
was about that same thing yeah they just
had different tales yeah you know me but
the the basic moral values of the
ancient Egyptians were about the same as
Christian and those Muslim values really
it seems like I mean how much dear moral
values are pretty pretty universal like
you know cheating on your wife don't
steal don't murder
yes that same because humans like I said
are really not that different no matter
what coast they just kind of interpret
it through different cultural lenses but
it's generally more similar than you
might say well yeah but they all had
multiple wives that's not the same as
cheating on your wife yeah that's just
there's another wife that's another
that's not Christian I actually know if
you go back to actually Christian do you
really look most of the ancient
Christians actually had multiple wives
and sort of Charlemagne had a whole
bunch of them yeah if you actually read
the Bible or the New Testament for what
it says religion is not excuse me
marriage isn't really between a man and
a woman it's between a man a woman a
woman a woman a woman a lemon on a woman
and all the hand maidens that serve all
those women that's really well yeah go
and look at the gold actually read what
it says yeah that's what it kind of
makes me laugh I'm like fundamentalist
Christians yeah good upset about
polygamy fundamental Christianity
actually describes a relationship
marriage is a man between a man a woman
a woman a woman a woman like all the
women that works for that woman and we
need woman that you saw any woman that
you paid for is also so don't can't
modern Christianity is not the same as
archaic Christianity exactly it's not
the same yeah there was a lot of
different it was a lot of different [ __ ]
back in the past yeah oh yeah so like I
said another interesting thing about
jinn that differentiates them from
angels and demons other than them not
being immortal and having to eat and
sleep and things like that like a human
does even though they're much stronger
than humans are much faster than humans
like I said they're invisible they can
some of them can shape-shift you know
things that they can travel really fast
like some of them can teleport or they
can like you know go from one place to
another like in a really really short
time um but the interesting thing too is
that they have free will just like
humans do so they can be other religions
they can be
disbelievers yeah they can be and
actually in the Quran I think it's uh
Sarah 72 I want to say there's a story
about Muhammad going he goes and you
know preaches to the humans and then he
goes and preaches to the jinn did the
jinn community like trying to get them
to like
come to all our whatever these parallel
populations yeah they're in a slightly
different universe yeah it's I'm a cool
idea it is that's what I mean that's
energy based life-form Kirk he ran
across a lot of them and green [ __ ]
green [ __ ] and energy pieces that's
yeah yeah yeah
and there's also um there's kind of a
relationship to with you know some of
the early like I said early Islamic
texts and the early you know text of
Judaism because King Solomon was said to
have been given by God control over the
jinn so he could like get the jinn to go
do stuff like I think he told he told
one Gen to like go get him queen Sheba's
throne or something like that he had
some kind of like controller there are
some stories later on that said he had
like a magical ring and stuff but I've
heard like some scholars say no that's
[ __ ] he just God told him hey you
can control the jinn and he's like
alright cool so I'm just gonna tell the
jinn to do this so there's kind of that
thing too and I think he also was able
to tell the jinn to build the first
temple so that's kind of a story that
turns up in a lot of folk tales later on
so an interesting thing too like I said
there's a bunch of different types of
them and I'll kind of probably get into
that after the break but here's
something interesting there's one
particular jinn and his name is and I'm
not sure if I'm pronouncing this right
but his name is a bliss or a bliss in
this yeah now he is kind of an analogue
to Satan or to Lucifer you know in the
Christian tradition but not quite
because his characters a little more
ambiguous generally the story with him
is that he was a jinn and he was somehow
in heaven with all the other angels even
though he's not an angel he's a jinn
well they can go to any dimension they
want to right right so you know Allah
says he Allah creates Adam and then he
says okay this is my creation the angels
and the jinn have to bow down to Adam
but it less as nah he says I'm made of
fire they're just made of clay or mud
I'm superior so he refused Wow
so then he kind of not so much gets
kicked out of heaven but he kind of
falls out of favor however he does ask
Allah hey can
go to earth and [ __ ] with the humans
like you know tempt them you know
basically just like the early say you
did so he actually had that similar kind
of role that is a reboot of the joy of
the job story yeah that's a that's an
Islamic interpretation of the same thing
that happened in job yeah that's what
that is
so generally like a bliss is called he's
called Shaitaan you know which Satan
Shaytan Shaytan but that is like not
that's not his name that's like a title
a title yeah and there are other ones
like whoa jinn are called
yeah yeah Shaytan is Shaytan and Satan
those are titles yeah it actually means
prosecutor grand prosecutor yeah or yeah
something like that is you know what's
and he has a similar kind of role like I
said is Lucifer right even though he
wasn't an angel he was actually even but
that's why even in the old you know
Judaic stories like job you can
interpret that story as Satan as the
grand prosecutor he's called him
[ __ ] on job yeah he's gonna say look
at Joe of only he's only worshiping you
cuz everything you gave him right let me
go down there put the fire on his ass
and okay we'll see we'll see we'll test
his mettle okay little Barbie yes so
what is Satan doing Satan is actually
serving God in that story yeah as his
prosecutor call him [ __ ] unbelievers
you know what I mean so the idea of a
rebel angel doesn't quite match up with
what happened back in in in the genesis
story about sons of God mating with the
daughters of women and creating Nephilim
and being in chained in the earth so
Satan is not being punished he's walking
up and down on the [ __ ] earth you
know he's free he can even go to heaven
yeah so Satan is not in Hell in any of
those stories only the only the
enchained Angels were the ones that had
to created the Nephilim yeah this whole
idea of Satan being in Hell is a modern
Christian concept Middle Ages yeah that
is not in there and it's also not I mean
embolus is not
you know it's not a kind of thing where
him and all are like at odds like right
now they work together yeah they work
together yeah all I was kind of pissed
because he was kind of like well hey I
told you to bow down to Adam and you
wouldn't but he wasn't so mad at him
that he wouldn't like let him go around
tempting humans and things right that
which I have a Southern Baptist
background okay I understand apocalyptic
beliefs yeah you can't throw revelations
at me and say well what about the beast
in the dragon from dr. price already
know that the Beast the false prophet
and the dragon have nothing to do with
Satan really when you get down to it the
dragon is Tiamat yeah the cosmic dragon
that Marduk's slayed to create the
universe the story about throwing the
dragon into the pit of hell means the
destruction of creation of the universe
in other words in the end of the
Revelation story God on creates the
universe because he no longer needs it
yeah that's what they're talking about
so I'm just I'm get about it okay so
don't you can't correlate Satan with the
dragon yeah those are different
characters and the interesting thing too
is that in the Islamic and pre-islamic
tradition
jinn are associated with several animals
you know cats and things like that but
are also probably most you know they're
usually most associated with snakes
serpents so you know that's another
analog right there of the whole serpent
in the garden bloody blah so they kind
of had their own version of it like I
seem to have yeah here's another one
though that I want to I would talk about
this serpent in in the garden yeah and
dr. price is gonna back me up on this
the serpent in the garden was not Satan
the serpent in the garden was a shara
and in the old pantheon Asura was the
Queen of Heaven all right ash row was
godswife she was punished okay for for
actually being man's benefactor about
eating the fruit of knowledge it's like
a Prometheus so just like Prometheus so
man could know the difference between
good and evil God punished
sharra by making her crawl on her belly
and she became a legless creature a
snake yeah okay
in the same way Prometheus was punished
for giving man fire yeah okay the
serpent in the garden is not Satan it's
Asura yeah and during that time it's
mentioned over and over again in the Old
Testament about Asherah poles because
Jews ancient Jews worship Bashara right
along with the father of heaven gosh it
was it el shaddai which is you know yeah
it the father of the gods which is this
what are you talking about the the
Jewish analog for Zeus the father of the
father of God right yeah it was a
pantheon surprising if those things
didn't bleed into one another because
they did exactly the ancient Greek
pantheon is exactly the same as the
ancient Jewish pantheon it's the same
thing they just had different names yes
many different stories that's what like
I said that's what fascinates me so much
about like comparative religion and
mythology it's like I'm always so
fascinated when I see different cultural
interpretations of what's generally the
same thing it's like the same figure and
like I said so the same thing happens
here with you know the whole thing with
Lucifer and a bliss being pretty much
and you know analogous type of yeah the
Jewish pantheon was just a hillbilly
version of the of the Greek pantheon it
was they were related all right so let's
see we're problem right halfway yeah
we're probably about the halfway point
so when we come back I want to kind of
talk about some of the different kinds
of jinn maybe like talk about a couple
of the little stories that were in
Thousand and One Nights about the jinn
and stuff like that so we're gonna take
a break right now and what I'm gonna say
boy I tell you what Google can't tear me
up but I know and I'm on the subject of
religion yeah it can be kind of like and
your little cheeks are turning red okay
we're top of the Jim I have like I well
I have what is this you made it yeah
mean it's naka and cherry and cheery
passion yeah
for our Islamic listeners don't don't be
upset okay we are going to talk about
the gym yeah seriously but yeah we're
brightness this is holy [ __ ] just just
add a school Khan and the Mesoamericans
okay the different kind of pyramid
different kind of temples sacrifice
myself we're all the same to the Jaguar
[Laughter]
all right we're gonna take a break right
now we'll be back okay everybody
ginnis got some new shirt designs up
four of them really good ones to Atlanta
Ripper who put Bella in the which out
the HH Holmes murder castle and of
course demon child cuz man said he could
these are updated designs I think they
look really cool Jenny did a great job
autumn where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah a
really good they're very high-quality
shirts Jenny and I we're sure our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put spotlight on ourselves and
you can put a spotlight on yourselves if
you go ahead and pick up on these shirts
today you guys are gonna love them links
in the description WWL comm at 13
o'clock yeah so go check out our store
at wwl com / 13 o'clock we got these
four cool new t-shirt designs plus all
our old ones if you'd rather get one of
the old ones but these ones are awesome
and you should check them out
they're also available in women's cut
and they look really cute Judy's got
some so thank you go check about
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back I'm talking about June
yes right getting drunk talking about
Jen you know I'm barely holding on I'm
barely did you see somebody on YouTube
my camera was but somebody on YouTube
commented that the jar was like a third
character yeah it is like you have to
drink out of the jar that's just the
rebels now well we're a 1970 style show
back when I was growing up on television
when you had celebrities getting drunk
on talk shows and game shows there's
hilarious it was super fun you can still
see a lot of them on YouTube yeah and if
we still smoked we would smell yeah
don't walk anymore that was the seat but
he still vape psych I actually made for
a long time that helped me quit smoking
but I don't have any nicotine in this
though it's just it's just it's just uh
make me feel better yeah it's totally
psycho lot of people are like talking
about Bates like oh you're such a douche
you blah blah but it's like seriously it
helped me quit yeah oh and I was like
for nearly 20 years and that helped me
quit smoking yeah I had smoked for a
long time to you and it's like that
actually it's immoral to ban those yeah
because it's like super helpful
yeah that's destroying smoking yeah
which is good that's a good thing talk
to him I mean you know everyone was
never here every now and then I still
want one but it's not not like it yeah
but yeah so anyway so let's talk a
little bit about gin so now like I said
there were belief in gin or gin like
entities prior to Islam kind of a you
know expanding outward but then as it
kind of started to expand outward into
you know Turkey and Africa and various
other areas around there you know other
their deities were also kind of
assimilated into it and like also called
jinn right now the interesting thing too
is that even though the Quran does not
as far as I know does not specifically
say that the the jinn can possess a
human but you know like a demon does but
that is a
very common belief even today like in a
lot of the Middle East now you know
where belief in gin is still prevalent
well maybe they believe that it can
possess a person like a demon it makes
sense because there's so many stories
about possession from other cultures and
other religions from the Islamic
viewpoint they're gonna say well yeah
we're not gonna call you Liars pizzette
possession happens yeah but that's gin
yeah
that's how you rationalize it because
like I said pretty much any supernatural
entity like what we would call a vampire
or a werewolf or something or a zombie
even right um is a jinn but it's just
like a different type of gin which that
gives a religious belief or religious
culture a certain advantage yeah because
when it comes into a new area of trying
to find new customers and instead of
rejecting the beliefs of the indigenous
people you can say no no the things that
you believe in are true but we as
Muslims call those chin yeah so it gives
you an advantage yeah it helps your
religion spread right because you're not
[ __ ] on people right they already
believe your eyes like oh well you're
right you're right yeah Jim called this
is called a jinn right and we have all
stories about jinn and jinn and the
rules of the jinn yeah which helps new
people coming into the religion explain
their old belief systems yeah and to
retain their belief systems okay yeah so
what we believed it's still true oh yeah
we just have a new understanding yeah it
was like a like the same thing that you
know Christians did when they were
taking over and they kind of
incorporated a lot of Christmas and they
just said oh well you guys can still do
that except now we're calling it this
interpreting it this way but you're
doing the same thing you know Halloween
good example yeah exactly
so that's kind of the same thing that
happened here so like I said there's
still like a lot of possessions to
restrict in Morocco there's a lot of
stories and actually on YouTube there's
a whole bunch of videos yeah people that
are possessed by jinn and like do yes
and as I've listened to Imams that speak
English
tell gen stories and Muslims love jinn
stories yeah in fact this
start warning the people are good I know
you guys want me to tell you June
sometimes stories
want to hear Jenna stories this and that
we need to talk about a lot but I tell
you what today just just so you stop
bothering me I'm going to tell you
stories about the Djinn in the amount
mom's start telling the stories about
Jim because they're young guys in it
young guys and yeah they're young guys
in the mosque and they want to hear
[ __ ] exciting stories about the
damage I was actually saying to BuzzFeed
has this podcast I've never heard of it
before but it's called if you see
something say something and it's it's
basically I'm like growing up Muslim in
America it's like it's just like a bunch
of young like hit people or whatever and
I was listening to their show they did a
show about jinn and it's just funny
because so I mean these are all like
20-somethings you know they're very
Americanized yeah and they said
everybody's grandpa and great-grandpa
has awesome awesome story about dams
yeah stories everybody and it's just
like how funny it's just funny because
that's something that you know I didn't
really experience you know what it's
ghost stories pretty much basically
thing that we have you know well cuz I
have those stories in my family too but
one of my favorite ones was like one of
the guys that was on there was talking
about his grandfather actually wrote a
book about his great-grandfather's all
his stories about Jen and stuff like
that and one of them in there and this
is a very common thing in like
supernatural you know entities like just
cross-cultural pretty much it's like
they're afraid of salts like if you make
like a ring of salt around yourself like
you're safe whatever reason so he's
talking about how his how his
grandfather his great-grandfather was
like in this ring of salt and he sees
like all these evil female jinn like
coming out and they were all holding
babies and then like one of them starts
eating the baby that it was cool and I
was like holy [ __ ] and it's like and he
kind of fainted inside the salt ring and
then like he was almost out of the salt
ring but then he woke up and he was okay
and like his buddy was like oh man if if
one hair of you had come out of that
ring the [ __ ] evil it was a great
[ __ ] story I'm like eating babies
holy [ __ ] yeah you know it's funny cos
like there's such a huge difference
between American Muslims Muslims in
Europe and Muslims in the Middle East
because I lived in Egypt for six months
and I was with the army and [ __ ] and
look it
Egyptians were a freaking trip all right
they're super friendly it's it's a weird
society I was hanging out most in Xiamen
place called Sharm el-sheikh which is in
in the Sinai Peninsula and there as MFO
soldier under the UN I was kind of like
a policeman at the time so I made a lot
of friends with the guys and the local
businesses there and I'm a Jin didn't
everything do that I everything I gotta
stop talking about it who are they I'm
just gonna say you know it was the way
is the way Egyptian people are at least
this was back in the in the 90s the way
they are is not really I hear a lot of
stereotypes here in the US the way
Muslims are yeah they're not really like
that when you when you meet them they're
really [ __ ] hilarious they're nice
people you know the weirdest thing about
it is that at the time that I was there
because their religious beliefs women
just don't walk around freely it was
almost kind of like there was just
nothing but men everywhere it was like
the world's largest gay bar but they're
not yeah it's a weird it's a weird it's
a weird it's a weird situation
sausagefest like yeah the whole world
yeah yeah yeah I'm not sure whether or
not you're not sure whether or not these
guys like you or they're trying to
[ __ ] put a move on you is this it's
just weird it's weird [ __ ] weird
welcome to women's problems yeah the
time seriously I was in my 20s back then
yeah that man so [ __ ] you know
handsome [ __ ] like me do you
know I just you know [ __ ] weird [ __ ] you
know I mean these guys that do weird
[ __ ] something you would say I mean your
your key by still but it's like you know
he was you looked like you looked a
little Tom Cruise ease you know that
type of yeah you had that cut cuz his
hair is black yeah my natural hair is
black it still is black his natural hair
colors so he had like black hair and
back in the 80s you had like that
feathered thing like ever
yeah my granddad was probably had some
Middle Eastern heritage in him it's
rumored probably Syrian yeah yeah Israel
the black hair came from one time I've
my brandy I'm on my mother's side yeah
because one time I photoshopped him onto
the cover of a team yeah from 1983 that
had like C thomas Howell or something
like I like I kind of erased see Thomas
Allen put him up there and everyone
bought it like everyone like I put it up
on Facebook just like yeah a teen idol
yeah and everybody was like what you
were on TV yeah Tiger Beat I was like
one of the hit members of Duran Duran
into a picture with the go-go's that was
actually my favorite one yeah because
that was like a perfect I found a
perfect food yeah I thought it [ __ ] up
here in the video if I can find it I
don't remember where they went to guys
like I did those a long time ago i
photoshopped him into a photo with
freddy mercury
yeah Evel Knievel I didn't like a whole
bunch of them they were super fun yeah
and I think I did a good job I think
that yeah it's really 16 I was probably
why his [ __ ] ever I had super
black hair and [ __ ] like white white
skin I got photographs of it you need a
show yeah I look like the the teenage
male version of died goddamn what was
her name [ __ ] do me more and people
tell me that back in those days you like
Demi Moore it's a man boy well then be
more if Demi Moore
yeah yeah that's kind of it's hard to
tell now because your hair is blonde and
it looked like totally different with
blonde hair yeah like I said normally so
anyway so like I said there's this whole
thing with this now let's kind of talk
about types of jinn yeah cuz they fall
into classification they fall into
classifications right now only three
types of jinn are actually mentioned in
Coran but there's actually way more of
that like in folklore tradition and
stuff like that now one of these is the
ghoul and this is it's in Arabic
tradition it spelled gh ul but it's
basically the same thing as a Western
ghoul that's where the concept came from
these are like grody cannibalistic
zombie type things that eat flesh and
rotten flesh and they hang out in
cemeteries and their own which this
actually kind of supports the Jesus
story I referenced earlier where there's
a possessed man out in a cemetery and
Jesus throws the spirits of the Evil
Dead out of him so you know Islamic
interpretation may have been he was
possessed by ghouls yeah animals that
were jinn that was there to eat the
rotten flesh and they got into this man
and yeah you throw them out into pigs so
like I said this is kind of like jinn
being like an umbrella term for every
single so this is kind of like your
zombie your ghoul this is what this is
evidently the most feared type of ghoul
is a female one because women be scary
this [ __ ] are crazy when they get
those supernatural powers you're [ __ ]
man I wish I would have used that [ __ ]
I'm telling you right now so nobody give
me supernatural powers yeah but yeah so
the female type is called a ghoul ah now
she can actually disguise herself as a
regular looking girl so she will like
kind of worm her way into a dude's heart
and then eat him that's what women do
though that's what I was gonna wear got
lots of those here in Florida we've got
lots of those here Florida okay I can
even point him out on Facebook we're
worming our way into all right so we can
eat you later
just once of those hot photos now and
colored hair no I'm not like that now
you're all right I'm
if you weren't if you weren't alright it
wouldn't be with you yeah yeah I'm cool
i'ma show them to you now some versions
of the ghoul actually the Persian
tradition has it where they have like
donkey legs and then they have like good
horns and [ __ ] like that but like I said
most then they kind of look zombie like
or they can look like a normal person
that busts out and eats you later on
there's also ones that are called Hin
and these are usually not shape-shifting
but they usually kind of show up as dogs
or doglike creatures usually like
piebald type of dogs are associated with
Hin there's also one this is kind of one
of the more famous ones it's called and
I think I mentioned this before
indifferent or Annie freaked yeah in
Dungeons & Dragons they were called the
afridi yes so like in higher spirits
right it's the same type of thing now
these are actually mentioned in the
Quran just one time
this is actually the reference from the
Quran is from this is the one that
Solomon told to go hello get the queen
of sheba's throne that was an Ifrit
these are actually usually evil
they're called infernal they're usually
really strong like really smart really
calculated they're usually like really
really big
they're made of fire they have wings and
[ __ ] like that they can be male or
female they hang out in kind of like
ruins or they live in caves like
underground or something like that kind
of like the Southern Baptist concept of
what a demon is and these are actually
the fire demon light um and they
actually live in a human-like society
that's kind of like a tribal type
Society they usually have it's a
hierarchical they have kings and you
know various other type of things you
know tribes clans that type of stuff
they can they they actually have
marriages they have stuff like that but
they have been known to marry humans and
folklore also I want to marry some yeah
so we're down here in case you know you
want to in case they get bored with
hanging out with other fire demons and
want to like marry support awesome and
then they've got porn of that they have
porn of everything but evidently that's
like you can't like do anything to them
like with reggae
weapons like that you can't like kill
them with a sword or nothing like that
but apparently some people can do magic
on them and you know hurt them and stuff
like that there are other ones that are
called Jan now these ones are
shapeshifters rather like werewolves I
suppose although they usually come out
like camels they're usually associated
with like they can turn into camels they
can also be wind you know there and
there's kind of like an association
there between wind demons and like
Pazuzu yeah it's a real demon like if
you saw the Exorcist I think they didn't
just pull that out their ass that's an
actual wind demon Oh kitty I just saw in
the background and sometimes like when
there's wind storms in the desert some
folklore says that that's like jinn
fighting with each other because a lot
because they're associated with like
wind and wind storms and things like
that but yeah so yeah Jan are they
generally hang out in the desert and
sometimes like in a lot of folkloric
stories from this part of the world they
will if they like a band of travelers
they will help you out if they don't
like you they will [ __ ] you up
also they will help out armies that they
like so they'll kind of pick a side in
an army and help them out so there's
like a lot of kind of folkloric stories
about the jam like helping out one side
or another in a particular battle
there's also ones called murid and these
are also mentioned in the Quran these
are actually really really big these
ones also turn up in Thousand and One
Nights and actually the word murid I
think is still refers to a giant in
various Arabic languages these are the
ones I think that this type is kind of
more like the Genie type or like they're
in the bottle they come out of there
really powerful they can do all this
kind of stuff because like I said not
all jinn can be controlled by people and
not all of them have the same powers
like some of them are stronger than
humans members timber the guy that I
worked with who was from Iraq mm-hmm and
I told him about that mountain
and he said oh yeah that's a gin part of
what he said was he he said that there
was a certain kind of witch that they
had in Iraq yeah I don't think she was
Muslim I think he was talking about some
kind of Zoroastrian witch and they could
come and trap as a Djinn that they would
actually come to a house where there was
some kind of weird poltergeist type
phenomenon going on and they would come
into the house and you would pay this
guy he trapped this Djinn and then he
would use it he would trap it inside of
a bottle and use it to find treasure on
his own yeah and if it was a good one
sometimes he would pay you for the jinn
that he got no some weird [ __ ]
yeah because I think yeah I think a lot
of the [ __ ] about people that do
witchcraft or sorcery and magic it's
like it's never interpreted as that
person like doing it it's always like oh
they control a jinn and then is the one
doing stuff like telling them the future
or whatever the power right and like I
said poltergeist activity in that part
of the world how they would interpret
that as a jinn right and that's that's
kind of really interesting and also
there have been like all these kind of
scholarly things where they're talking
about jinn and what you know what
metaphorically that could mean and
sometimes they'll say something like oh
it's like some kind of quantum energy or
it's some kind of interdimensional being
or it could be like a metaphor for a
virus bacteria because a lot of them
were said to cause illnesses and I've
seen classic poltergeist phenomena
myself personally and people in my
family if if a person were there in the
house with us at that time had suggested
that a poltergeist could find a lost a
lost object may be located gold I bet
you would have done it yeah so maybe in
a poltergeist type situation a person
could actually channel the poltergeist
phenomenon into a profit-making
situation where you actually get a
message of where some gold was lost yeah
because it's I think it has to do with
kind of like
some kind of quantum knowledge you know
what I mean
like a accessing some kind of a Kashuk
record yeah where something was lost I
would saw a program the other day where
a physicist was talking about like hyper
dimensional geometry and now as you back
up off of dimensions parts of us touch
everything in other dimensions with that
so we I couldn't comprehend it he says
if you could understand quantum physics
then you're lying yeah but you know it
could be every place is here you know I
mean where you are is in another
dimension attached to somewhere else and
if you could access that information you
could find out where anything was yeah
you know I mean yeah because every piece
is this place every place is this place
if you start going up into higher
dimensions right it's almost kind of
going up higher and so you can see
further right right exactly because
we're only in three dimensions right now
right as far as but maybe there's more
of us in a higher like a fourth spatial
dimension and that fourth spatial
dimension may have access to every place
in these three dimensions right there's
some about what but it's got a t' hyper
dimensional geometrical theoretical
object that less than a hundred guys on
the planet I truly understand understand
that's why like I said that's why I was
kind of fascinated by the whole jinn
thing because it's almost like way back
then they had a concept of other
dimension right right they just
humanized it right you know what I mean
it's like maybe stories and legends yeah
that we're in like another dimension
essentially they didn't know they didn't
have the words to express that right but
that's pretty much what they were
talking they're talking about it was
like somebody there like around us all
the time but we just can't see them like
we can't perceive them with our senses
right that's kind of exactly what
they're talking in the Islamic cultures
they're doing with these jinn what we
did with spirits of the Dead ghosts
that's right yeah it's pretty much the
same pretty much same concept yeah we're
putting it on a different on a different
entity yeah and like I said I'd like the
idea that they didn't necessarily say oh
they were all bad they were just like
people some of yeah soft and some of
them were awesome you can preach - you
ready yeah like you could actually go
and someone would be like oh yeah I'll
be Muslim or I'll be a Christian or
whatever cuz they could be whatever
religion there were Buddhist ones they
were all right they're all well during
this era where all these stories are
coming around a lot of the Muslims were
Bedouin yeah I'm better weena and you
know if you're ever out in the desert at
night in the in Bedouin areas I've been
there it's beautiful at night you know I
mean and you're around the campfire he's
looking at stars the way the way the sky
looks is awesome in that part of the
world you're gonna tell stories and your
minds gonna you know so you know you're
gonna have fanfiction based on you know
I'm gonna start writing fanfiction based
on old religions and that's where this
stuff is coming from and like I said you
kind of have like pretty much every type
of jinn has like an analogue and another
type of supernatural creature you got
your shapeshifters you got your ghouls
you got kind of some they're like
vampiric sort of yeah also I think
there's actually one called a palace or
a palace that's essentially like a
vampire except he sucks blood out of
your feet like the bottom of your feet
yeah like the only way you can thwart
him by like sleeping with your feet
against somebody else's head or like I
guess wearing socks or shoes would
probably throw them as well because some
of the some of the Jenner and like not
so smart and they can be outsmarted by
people but some of them are actually
much smarter but there's actually one -
there's there's one called an AZ nests
and that's I think there's a couple
stories about him in the thousand and
one nights and this is like super weird
he's like half human not in the sense
that he's half human and half something
else but he's just like half of a purse
like he has a half of a head he has one
arm and one leg and like hops around
yeah like he's a half human yeah that's
exactly I was really like half human
like half human half what is there
another half walking around somewhere
else yeah
look maybe not like the whole thing
that's just like what he's like right
okay that's like pretty weird right and
that an extension of that there's kind
of a version of that from Somalia that
is kind of like similar cities just like
a half a little person that's hopping
around and evidently there's a there's a
belief that if this one thing touches
you then you'll die yeah you know so
like I said yeah so you got your Shaytan
which are like the evil ones kind of you
know like a Satan or demon type figure
these ones actually the the interesting
thing about the shaitan they're the
shaytan ones is that they lay eggs like
snakes Wow you know I mean which I
thought that was pretty weird and
they're always like really ugly or like
really serpentine type of and then
there's also one called a sheik which is
like a kind of a lower form one they
usually look like monsters and then
there's one called a salat which is
usually like a really smart one and they
can also shape-shift and various animals
and stuff like that so like I said I
think the kind of you know the most
common stories that people know in the
West are the Aladdin story and I Dream
of Jeannie which like I said and it's
weird because the Aladdin story is not
that actually wasn't in the original
Thousand and One Nights I was actually
added in the 18th century seventeenth
eighteenth century when they there was a
French translation of it and somebody
like whoever wrote the French
translation had heard this story from
like a Syrian or something like that of
Aladdin and the wonderful lamp and put
it in there so this actually wasn't a
super you know so the the perception of
like a genie popping out of a lamp and
giving you you know what you wishes yeah
and stuff like that it's not a real
common theme although one of the more
famous stories in the Thousand and One
Nights is actually called the fishermen
in the genie and it's kind of a similar
thing where it's like there's this
fisherman and his wife and he goes out
to the little pond every day and he
throws his net into the pond four times
every
I don't know why just four but he's just
like four times every day and then he
does okay like he pulls in fish and
stuff like that but this one day he is
just having [ __ ] luck it's like he
throws his net in the first time he
pulls it back up there's like a dead
horse or a dead donkey in there and he's
like like me and then he throws the net
back out then he comes he pulls it back
in and this time it's just like a jar
full of sand or some kind of [ __ ] and
he's like [ __ ] and then like he throws
it back in then he pulls it back and
then it's like [ __ ] broken pottery
pieces and he's like god damn it so it's
like he throws it back one more time
then he pulls it back in and there's
like a little copper jar and it has like
the Seal of Solomon on it and he's like
oh what's this and he pries it open a
poof out comes a genie
now the genie does not say oh I grant
you three wishes first he thinks the
dude is King Solomon because that's who
his King Solomon was the [ __ ] that
put him in there right so he's like no
I'm not King Solomon he's like okay well
here's the deal
he's like I got put he's like King
Solomon died like a thousand years ago
man it's like you're so out of the loop
so the fisherman so the fisherman is
like you know I'm not King Solomon so
the genie says all right he's like first
hundred years that I was in this [ __ ]
jar I was like you know whoever gets me
out of this jar I'm gonna you know I'm
gonna give him all this wealth and stuff
and then nobody let me out some like a
hundred years later you know oh well
maybe someone will let me out now and
I'll give him three wishes but that
didn't [ __ ] happen either he's like
now like four hundred years later now
I'm [ __ ] pissed and now I'm thinking
whoever finds this jar it opens and I'm
just gonna kill his ass I will let him
choose how he dies okay so that's what
he says to the fisherman just choose how
you die the fishin was like wait we wait
he's like just let's just think about
this for a second
and he's like let me just tell you a
story so then they start telling each
other stories so then they become buds
right so then finally the genie is like
all right well I won't kill you because
you seem like all right dude so he's
like so I'll give you something cool so
he tells him that there's this pond he's
like go to this one pond and put your
net in like you usually do like four
times but whatever you catch you got to
take it to the Sultan right so the guy
like okay so he goes and he puts you
know and he just does the net and
everything and he brings in like all
these really beautiful fish like they're
all like these all crazy colors and
stuff like that so he does what the
genie says and he takes him to the
Sultan and then it turns out that the
town that the Sultan was you know ruling
over had been cursed by some sorceress
or some [ __ ] and they had turned like
all the people in the town into fishes
so those were like the townspeople in
there so he had like so the fisherman
had actually brought them out and said
hey here's the pond where that stupid
[ __ ] like put all these [ __ ] fish in
there
and he's like now we can turn him back
into humans they found out where the
sorceress was and they destroyed her and
so the fisherman was like Lunt the
Sultan was like man the fisherman he's
the man you know he showed us where the
pond was we got all our people back and
so they gave him like all these riches
and the genie gave him all these riches
so that's kind of where the seed of the
Aladdin story came from but like I said
it's it's not so much you know yeah
there was the whole thing about King
Solomon being able to control genies and
stuff like that but that's it's it's
just a very small part of jinn lore yeah
you know what I mean and it's funny that
that seemed like the best the the main
thing that people in the West like know
about genies but yeah so before we wrap
it up I just wanted to talk about a
couple of sort of similar things or like
kind of a prologue to the type of jinn
story like I said I think I mentioned
before
Pazuzu from The Exorcist yeah who
actually was like a real thing he was a
sumerian wind demon type thing also kind
of similar to the jinn concept he sort
of had like a doglike head and like a
snake penis and chilli which in wings
and whatnot who wouldn't want that would
you
snake we talked about anaconda right
[Laughter]
yeah now one of the most interesting
things that I thought was like in very
very old Judaism and like a lot of the
folklore from that period they actually
had a thing called a shedding which was
almost exactly like a jinn it was pretty
much it was invisible like most humans
couldn't see it
but they still like procreated they
still had to eat they still had to sleep
and it was also kind of like they were
around before Adam and then like
basically like I got replaced by humans
and they were like jealous about it so
that kind of concept was floating around
in the area before the concept of jinns
really like codified and one type of
thing so there have been like kind of
analogs in you know prior to the Islamic
concept and prior to you know this you
know like I said we don't really have
there's not an exact thing in the
Christian tradition I think we kind of
maybe lost that but Judaism did have a
concept very similar to jinns we just
sort of lost I think Christians just
kind of were just like everything's
Damons yeah you know what I mean
angels and demons that's it yes whereas
whereas demons and jinn are two very
distinct entities like you could say
that Christians also believed in
vampires and werewolves that might be in
there but those are more like monsters
not yeah not really supernatural or not
a theological no I'm not religious no
more like something from the natural
world because I feel like jinn they have
a folklore component but they're but
it's a theological concept like I said
it's in there in the Koran they're
mentioned like 28 times 30 times
something like that in the Korean so
they are a thing you know in Islamic
theology and in pre you know in pre
Arabic you know before they don't have
to say it to any non-western people
living all right listening Christians
believed in vampires and werewolves not
because they were in the Bible they
weren't in the Bible it's because they
kept finding dead women so something did
this they didn't really think it was men
doing it they thought it was men that
turned into wolves or dead people
walking around killing people
yeah that was the explanation because
they were like too naive to think that
just like a regular ride could do that
kind of [ __ ]
basically what werewolves were were
serial killers yeah I kind of feel like
yeah yeah
and people doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] and they
couldn't conceive yeah and vampires were
bait was basically tuberculosis or the
plague yeah that's what they're talking
about whole families they find him dead
in the house I do feel a me a vampire
and actually a lot of the vampire
mythology that kind of came because we
talked about this a little bit on our
news for tuberculosis yeah it was like
it's basically a play like analog you
know that's pretty much exactly what
they're talking about and in the vampire
stories wherever a vampire was plagues
were there no vampires were the plague
the plague was the vampires yeah that's
that's all it was people died in a damn
beacon of vampires we actually watched
on its on shudder
we watched yeah the Dan Curtis Dracula
that had Jack Palance as Count Dracula
made a good Dracula it was actually
pretty good I had heard about it but I
said it was made for TV I believe yeah
correct me if I'm wrong but I had heard
about it like over the years and I never
seen it so we actually kind of what it
actually streamlined the story a lot
took out Renfield which was very odd
took out Quincey Morris which most
adaptations do actually Jonathan
Harker's role was significantly depleted
like he was kind of like in the
beginning of it and then he kind of
disappeared for a long time I like to
everyone just forget about Harker what
happened to him and then like he sort of
turns up at the end like for five
seconds but uh you know it's so
concentrated more on Lucy and Mina and
that kind of stuff
but it was I it was actually not bad
maybe we'll do a review yeah alright so
I think we probably gone long enough
unless you have anything else you'd like
to add about gin no like I said gin were
the Islamic explanation for the
paranormal if they ever saw a paranormal
stuff doable that's a jinn yeah because
it was already in there in there in
there in there mythological less account
right so let's just say you had an old
Arab walking around out in the desert
and he sees a damn alien spacecraft
flying through the air he's gonna say I
saw Djinn well yeah and like I said when
I was watching that BuzzFeed video Lyra
girl she said basically I mean she was
you know she had grown up Muslim she was
a paranormal investigator though and she
said okay basically you know whereas in
the United States if you see something
weird you're gonna atribute it - she's
like whereas in the Middle East it would
basically well it was a jinn it's just
like some you know form of jinn and that
was the cultural reference right exactly
and like I said they could manifest
themselves in lots of different ways so
it was almost kind of like yeah all the
stuff like vampires werewolves aliens
whatever it's all just one thing they're
just turning up in different they
inherited stories about jinn yeah so
they saw something they couldn't explain
they would just say it was the jinn that
did it yeah I saw so there's a good
chance that maybe in the Islamic part of
the world you'd have poltergeist and
ghosts and maybe even UFO phenomena
happening they're gonna tell you a jinn
story after they saw some [ __ ] like yeah
I read some really good ones everybody I
said everybody had a good gin story you
know when they asked for one cuz like I
said it's like everybody's got a good
good some gin stories are hoaxes you can
find those online on Facebook there's
some really cool things where they got
some guys in a mosque and they're
standing around there's a little [ __ ]
thing there's got a [ __ ] it's got a
suit on and it's prayed to Allah and
it's something I don't know if it's a
snake with something thrown over it or
if it's a little robot a
remote-controlled creature or something
doing this back and forth but it's
moving back into forth and it's praising
a lot it's singing and it's got and
they're in the mosque I'm gonna say it's
a jinn I think it might have been a
snake yeah with it with a towel thrown
over it it's hard to say
I saw one like on that channel that top
five channel yeah and these are like top
five creepiest Djinn sightings or
whatever boys remember just like
standard like look like standard
possession type stuff which is labeled
flailing around and screaming but the
first one was supposedly was some kind
of like CCTV camera footage and it was
pretty weird because it looked like this
dude that was just crawling around in
the street like in the middle of the
night like in the snow yeah and it was
like the the quality of it was bad but
it looked like a dude just crawling
around you're like what the [ __ ] is he
just like super drunk or but I figured
he was just like a drunk but they what
they were
like making it's like oh well that's
obviously a gin it's not just some drunk
like don't for one second think that
[ __ ] Arabs won't try to hoax your ass
cuz they will everyone I saw some
[ __ ] bad-ass videos that they made
where they they made this little
deformed dog like looking body and a guy
put it a guy put his face up in and see
you see his hand and it's got this
little bitty body it's totally hugs and
they're videotaping oh yeah it looked
awesome it looked awesome I mean if you
look at the there was all this little
Arabic you know they were making
comments on it all in Arabic you know in
bases back when you could ask for to
transfer translations on YouTube they
don't do that anymore
and you could hear we're going oh that's
a hook sir oh that's like this gin and
you know people need to stop having sex
with the animals that's hilarious
Arabs got a sense of humor they do is it
look like the dog with the human head
like from yeah it looked like it looked
like across did a dog and a baby with a
human head and its eyes are moving it
looked like it was like sitting on top
of something it was behind bars like
they had it in a Cell yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's a trick I love a good yeah
especially if they're well done if I was
like hey yeah I've been you know I lived
in Egypt Arabs a hoax the [ __ ] out of
you usually around the Quran and it's
usually around [ __ ] jinn and you know
having fun with it yeah yeah you know so
anyway hope you guys enjoyed this show
hope I didn't get too much [ __ ] wrong
because like I said this was a topic I
didn't know a lot about so I spent a
last last couple days research in it and
actually was kind of fascinating like
all the stories and stuff and I just
find the whole like I said comparative
religion comparative mythology thing
really fascinating so hopefully you guys
did too and also if you liked the show
remember to Like share subscribe on all
your social media and if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
or you can go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast on wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation if you don't want to
use patreon for whatever reason also
remember to check out our regular
episodes like this one right here which
come out every Tuesday we also do a
movie retrospective old movie that comes
out every Friday and we do new movies
three of them that we go see in the
theater every week and those come out on
Sunday it's called 13 o'clock matinee so
check that out if you haven't already
and that will do it for episode 119 and
we will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]